everyone who studied relativity is
familiar with the twin paradox
the setup of two siblings who travel
separate paths across space and time
and when reunited are found to be
different ages
they're probably also familiar with the
conventional solution to the paradox
in which the acceleration of the
traveling twin is given to be
the underlying catalyst of the twins
differing experiences
but it turns out this solution is only
valid for a very specific
case that is in the flat space time of
special relativity
step into the world of curved space time
however
and this conventional answer suddenly no
longer applies
indeed in this strange warped reality
the twin paradox becomes well
even more paradoxical
this is dialect with the twin paradox
incurred space-time
[Music]
for the last century or so we've been
told the key to resolving the twin
paradox
lies in the fact that in order to remain
younger than their sibling
one of the twins has to accelerate but
in 2009
two european physicists published a
paper where they demonstrated that this
isn't always the case
entitled adding to the paradox the
accelerated twin is older
the paper presents a scenario where the
twin who accelerates
actually ages more than their sibling
the twist this twin paradox takes place
in curved space-time as opposed to flat
space-time
now the difference between flat
space-time and curved space-time
is the subject of many a thick textbook
but at the moment
all we really need to understand is that
flat space-time
models environments where gravity
doesn't have a significant presence
while curved space-time models those
where it does
and since the traditional twin paradox
is formulated
in the absence of gravitational
considerations this means
it occurs in flat space-time but what
happens if we throw gravity into the mix
to answer this question the authors of
the 2009 paper devised a simple setup
one twin let's call her alice sits at an
unchanging position in space
while the other twin we'll call him bob
flies around in a circle
starting and ending at alice's location
now in empty flat space-time this
situation resembles the classic twin
paradox scenario
one twin is at rest the entire time so
her clocks tick fastest
while the other twin travels away at a
high velocity so his clocks tick slower
and although each should see the other's
clock ticking more slowly
the classical explanation also tells us
that because bob has to accelerate and
feel a force
in order to fly around in a circle he
will also observe for alice
time contracting effects which in
negating and opposing the time dilation
effects
ultimately cause her clocks to speed up
leading them both to agree
that she is the older twin but rather
than hang around in boring old flat
space time
the authors take this setup and embed it
in a curved space
time with the schwarzschild-like metric
or in other words they place a mass in
the center of bob's circular path
now because of the gravitational
attraction from that mass
bob can just like a satellite above the
earth
maintain his circular path via orbital
freefall
meanwhile alice in order to resist
falling into the mass
has to constantly fire her rockets
the authors of this paper then ask if we
run this same scenario again
who will be the older twin after turning
through the math
they discover the result is that the
orbiting twin
bob will be younger than his sibling
at first glance this may not seem too
surprising
after all it's the same result as you
would get in the flat space time setup
but this answer comes despite the fact
that the roles of who
is accelerating and who isn't have been
completely reversed
that is in the flat space-time scenario
bob has to accelerate to fly around in a
circle
while alice remains at rest whereas in
the curved space-time scenario
bob doesn't have to accelerate at all
but can simply follow
an inertial path through curved
space-time while alice has to fire her
rockets to remain
in place think about it for a moment
this is actually a revolutionary result
it changes everything we thought we knew
about the twin paradox
but to truly understand it we need to
take a few steps back
let's start by taking a closer look at
the traditional twin paradox
you probably know the typical story by
now one twin stays on earth while the
other blasts off into space
before accelerating to turn back around
and return home
turns out this setup is actually rather
misleadingly formulated
though simple and easy to follow having
one twin
always accelerate while the other
doesn't makes it appear
as if acceleration is the defining
distinction
between the twins experiences
but we can just as easily have the two
twins blast apart in different
directions
than have one twin fire their rockets to
return home sooner than the other twin
in this setup since both twins will at
some point or another have fired their
rockets
they both can claim to have inhabited
non-inertial frames or accelerated
during their journeys yet when they are
reunited
still only one will be older
this should already indicate to us that
acceleration cannot be the
only decisive factor in resolving the
paradox
indeed in a case such as this the
determining factor becomes not who did
or didn't accelerate on their journey
but rather who accelerated or turned
around earlier
that is if say alice is the one who
turns around first
then upon reunion with her brother she
will be the older one
because her planes of simultaneity will
skip over less time than bob's indeed
the sooner alice turns around in her
journey the older she will become with
respect to bob
notice of course that we can recover the
traditional twin paradox in the limiting
case
where alice turns around instantaneously
or
in other words just stays put on earth
another way to look at this is if we
chart the twins respective paths on a
space-time diagram
the twin who travels the greater
space-time distance
is always the older one as an aside here
it's important to note that because of
the negative sign in the flat space time
metric
shorter distances in space time
correspond to longer distances
on a space-time diagram yes we know it's
confusing
thus remaining the younger twin requires
not
merely accelerating but also traveling
an
overall shorter path through space-time
now in special relativity these two
phenomena are intrinsically linked
because accelerated motion always
results in a shorter space-time path
consequently this means non-accelerating
or inertial motion
always establishes the longest possible
path between any two events
but in general relativity the
correlation between such frameworks
begins to shift because as it turns out
inertial paths through space-time are no
longer necessarily the longest
this is because general relativity takes
a great conceptual leap
forward with the idea of the inertial
frame
in special relativity inertial frames
are defined
wherever objects travel in straight
uniform lines with respect to one
another
but in general relativity inertial
frames are recast
as something else altogether frames
where observers or objects
are in gravitational free fall
thus in general relativity anything that
travels along a path
influenced solely by gravity is in an
inertial frame
whether that path is a straight line or
not
a satellite orbiting the earth an apple
falling to the ground
susie rising and falling after bouncing
off her trampoline
these are all examples of traveling in
an inertial frame
in general relativity this shift in
conceptualization came about
because einstein realized that there was
no way to distinguish
at least locally between being
accelerated by a homogeneous
gravitational field
and being at rest he deduced
that this meant that gravitational
acceleration wasn't real at all
but rather only an apparent form of
acceleration
one which like centrifugal acceleration
or other fictitious accelerations
arises upon incorrectly judging the true
motion
of one's frame of reference
so although one can appear to be
accelerating when they are falling
towards the earth
or circling in orbit above it they are
not actually experiencing any force at
all
but rather only traveling in uniform
motion in inertial frames
these inertial frames are however
subject to the curvature of space-time
and well the trick behind curvature is
that parallel lines
don't have to stay parallel rather they
can eventually
converge or diverge like lines of
longitude on a globe
likewise for inertial frames that rest
with respect to one another
their initial movements through time or
their world lines
start out parallel but can be made to
converge if the dimension of time
and space through which they move i.e
space-time
curves in just the right way
this is in a very brief nutshell why
inertial paths through space
can appear to converge under tidal
forces or even circle back on themselves
in orbital motion
this curvature is also why an inertial
path through space-time
might not necessarily be the longest one
the straightest path between two points
on a globe for instance
is not necessarily the shortest since
one can always take the long way around
similarly
inertial paths through space-time while
being the straightest paths possible
don't have to be the longest
now let's go back to our twin paradox in
curved space-time
in the scenario presented by the authors
of the 2009 paper
the orbiting twin is subject only to the
gravitational force
which again in general relativity means
he is not accelerating at all
but rather traveling with uniform
inertial motion
through curved space-time
he never has to fire his rockets and can
therefore claim to be at rest the entire
time
meanwhile the other twin the stationary
one
has to fire her rockets and accelerate
the entire time
in order to fight the curvature of
space-time and remain a constant
distance away from the central mass
she therefore feels a force or inhabits
a non-inertial frame
for the entire duration that her twin is
in orbit
now according to the conventional
explanation to the twin paradox the twin
who ages less
should be the twin who accelerates or
feels a force during the journey
yet in the scenario in curved space-time
this criteria
completely fails us because the orbiting
twin despite never accelerating
and never experiencing a force still
winds up traveling the shorter
space-time path
and therefore comes back younger
meanwhile
the twin who is constantly firing her
rockets ends up
older what does this mean
well it demonstrates conclusively that
acceleration
does not resolve the twin paradox
this is a shocking result namely because
it means the explanations we've been
given for the last hundred plus years
have been definitively
and undeniably wrong or at least grossly
incomplete
it also makes all the offshoot
explanations like the popular
switching frames one entirely irrelevant
this is validating news for the skeptics
among us who always found such solutions
to be a little suspect in the first
place these solutions
after all rely on the notion of absolute
acceleration
a notion so poorly defined that even
einstein thought it was absurd
but if the conventional solution is
wrong just what then
is the solution this was the immediate
problem
that cropped up for the authors of the
2009 paper
and they attempted to resolve it by
suggesting that the asymmetry of the
twin paradox
must instead stem from the differing
velocities of the twins
with respect to some globally defined
standard of rest
that is they said the twin who travels
fastest
with respect to a global standard of
rest will always end up younger
meaning velocity ultimately wins out
over acceleration
but a number of papers published in
response to the 2009 one
quickly demonstrated that this new
conclusion was itself
equally flawed by setting up a third
twin paradox scenario
these other papers showed that in the
same short shield like curved space-time
setup
you can have a situation in which the
twin who travels with a higher velocity
actually ends up older this new setup is
almost simpler than the other two
both twins begin at a point some
distance away from a gravitational mass
and as in the earlier scenario one twin
stays in place
with respect to that mass firing the
rockets in order to do so
the second twin however is launched
radially outward at a high velocity
then allowed to free fall in the masses
gravitational field
until they rejoin their twin
this setup resembles the orbital setup
and the fact that the twin who stays in
place
has to accelerate while the twin who is
traveling
is in inertial freefall for the entire
trip
now however the outcome is reversed the
unaccelerated
free-falling twin is older upon the
twins reunion
while the accelerating twin is younger
showing that
curved space-time can accommodate
solutions in which the accelerating twin
can be either younger
or older meanwhile
based on these considerations the papers
conclude that velocity with respect to a
global standard of rest
can no more be responsible for the
asymmetry of the paradox
than can acceleration ultimately these
considerations suggest
that there is but one and only one
criteria
for resolving the twin paradox that of
the lengths of the twins respective
space-time paths
that is no matter whether space-time is
curved
or flat the twin who travels the shorter
space-time path
will always come out younger in flat
space
time a shorter path always requires an
act of acceleration
but this fact does not generalize to
curved space time
where the shorter path can belong to the
inertial twin
so what does this all mean for the twin
paradox
in one fell swoop we can cross three
popular answers
acceleration feeling force and changing
frames
off from our list of possible agents of
asymmetry for the paradox
all of these have been routinely offered
up as candidates in the past
and it's nice to know that we can
conclusively move beyond them but that
still leaves the ultimate question
of what really breaks the symmetry what
truly resolves the paradox
to begin answering this we'll need to
understand
what actually goes into determining the
length of a space-time path
but we'll have to dig into that later
because this has been a lot to digest
and right now our heads are spinning a
little but certainly
we won't stop exploring the mystery of
the twin paradox in future videos
this has been dialect thanks for
watching